welcome to this video again this video
I'm going to show two games on one case
mainly a one position none of them from
the currently running masters final
played then yeah the second leg we
played we played in Bilbao and the third
the first one is now being plated Sao
Paulo Brazil so they show that they
switch locations in the middle of the
tournament um yeah we've got six players
competing here very very top filled with
the world number one Magnus Carlsen
playing what number to Levon Aronian
that of course world champion vishy
anand and the three additional players
not better not better as well we've got
Sega coyoacán um fabiano caruana and
Francesco vallejo bones and after four
rounds some it looks that kawana it's
running away with this he he's on plus
three three wins and two draw which adds
up to a 3100 rating performance and here
you can clearly see that the first game
of a tournament really sets the tone as
Kara wanna at a lost position in the
first round against Carlton in which
kasnije made them very very young costly
miscalculation and lost the game even
and after that kawana is just winning
every game besides one draw against on
earth and in this game he was also
better I mean not winning but he was
pressing in this game so if Caruana can
can somehow keep this pace um he'll
certainly this would certainly Marcus
breakthrough as a clear world
championship candidate um if that's not
the case already alright so let's have a
look at the fourth round here and the
first game i'm going to show you but
only quickly in the beginning because
it's just one
specific position that self-interest is
between what number one and what number
two cards need aronian so let's go
through this quickly cars and playing
1.e4 and we get the Berlin defense and
cards none doesn't up for the for the
end game with castles so no Berlin Wall
endgame this very topical endgame that
both players play with both colors no
interest is this time we played III to
get them a more full blooded down fight
okay Bishop c5 and now takes on c6 this
leads to a very well-known pawn
structure this can also rise from the
exchange variation 1 differences that in
the exchange white very often goes for d
4 at one point to the exchange those
pawns and then get this four against
three majorities also the position opens
up and it often gets a rather technical
in this kind of setup though with 92
here white wants to keep the central
pawns and play for our 4f form at some
point or maybe with pieces no an ID to
h4 to f5 stuff like that so it's a
rather close position um by the way
white cannot take here because of yeah
right this idea or in this case even
this is possible threatening mate and
and the night alright so but I don't
want to show too much about them this is
this part of the game it's rather on
brother normal here young black gum just
hex this this night off and now it's a
very solid position in the center g3 um
it's an interesting move that surprised
me a bit to play g3 with without a light
square Bishop but white simply wants to
go night h4 and black preempt that with
playing f5 himself this is an
interesting decision and one that is
difficult for lots of players because
look at the structure right now we'll
get this some nice square on e4 we'll
see what happens Queenie 2 and white now
has this 94 idea let's continue so wyd
to manage to get this night to this
dream square and before where it is
impossible to dislodge them in there is
no pawn that can attack it I'm but
income as compensation look at the
position Black has got enormous pressure
on the F file so he's got them got them
get something in return and this is
always difficult to assess and the
better you are as a player the more
accurate your evaluation becomes of
those factors it's a little bit like the
older Bobby Fischer saying in order to
get squares you need to give squares
here aronian gave away the e4 square but
ok didn't get a specific square maybe f3
if you want but he got some peace
activity so he got something in return
and this is really a trademark of a
strong player that you can assess
correctly and those kind of yeah
exchanges you get something and you give
something so i think this position is
this around equal no h5 getting the
Queen back and wide got rid of his a
porn and maybe has some ideas at some
point on the fr but you see that black
has some play on the King side so it's
not easy for for--why to make any kind
of progress quindi one queen age three
so um yeah now we have the position i
was i was talking about the interesting
point of the game here carlton played
and you can see the times are fairly
accurate he had lots of time on the
clock like Bishop f4 so attacking the
rook and breaking the connection between
the two pieces of the ruckus hanging
but still it's a move that strikes you
as something with as a bit weird I know
and in this position aronian with 12
minutes on the clock played the move
after two minutes Bishop's III okay
let's return you and you can maybe look
at this position as some sort of
technical puzzle get give yourself a bit
of time and trying to find something for
black here alone pause this form for a
couple of seconds and be quiet so that
you can pause the video all right here
in this position Aronian could simply
win the game with the rook takes after
and for him and white white simply
resins this there's nothing else then
taking night takes and then like
threatening a queen G to check and okay
you might say well rook g1 yeah I'm
covering this but then here's the point
Queen f2 King F to look at three so uh
nice mate out of the yeah not out of the
blue but still a bit surprising that
it's a it's possible I think it's very
weird that Aronian didn't see didn't see
this because it's four players of this
level I think it's a matter of seconds
to see this I mean it's not not want to
show off here but I saw it after a
couple of seconds also i have no idea
what he was doing maybe at least I saw
the idea I think he must have saw on the
idea as well but maybe saw some kind of
ghost I'm not sure one possibility is if
you look at this position Knight takes
maybe ruka eight was irritating him this
is a possibility because at first you
might think okay how you need to go here
and then you've got light g5 coming and
then the Queen on
after this it's just the same but there
are some brew pubs there's simply this
move and white resigns again so just the
same I know he must have overlooked
something here because the fun thing is
if you look look at the game in the game
he played the weird-looking move Bishop
to c3 and cousin responded with Queen
takes rakia ok but what would happen
after night xe3 the only move of black
and play now that keeps him in the game
even it's looped x f4 with the same kind
of idea so I think he saw the idea but
somehow belief that Nigel here that the
night is on c3 so this is not an idea at
all and if white were to check now you
simply move the king and there's no
check and we have the same mate coming
of course why doesn't need to take on c3
but he saw the idea but he must have I
know instantly must have confused him so
we have the very rare occurrence of a
double blunder Bishop f4 just loses the
game and bishops III doesn't win the
game rook takes f4 would've won and now
Carlton can actually save himself you
take us on our three Bishop takes here
Queen g2 and it's a bit technical but at
the end we have just a similar position
to the one before only with the yeah one
rook exchanged and it's very difficult
to make any progress for for both sides
so I'll go through the rest and rather
quickly there wasn't much happening
really yeah Brooks got off and now we
have more exchanges yeah and perpetual
at the end Black is just too active
attacking all the bouncer wide let's
take the perpetual would be interesting
to know if the players realized during
the game what what they had overlooked
they're both had overlooked
it's really a really funny I mean it's
very very rare those kind of players
some overlooked yea rather easy tactics
it's really nothing special for them to
spot this yeah okay so now I have a look
at we'll have a look at them the game
that koala played yesterday I'm afraid I
need to put you up the video a little
bit i'm sorry Kara wanna and sorry for
this we didn't get seasick or the both
movements so now we have caruana against
the vallejo hope i pronounced this
halfway correctly um and we have 1.e4
karana played them if won this
tournament as usually does we got a
french in the first round Carlton also
played the French as a little bit of a
surprise and their car wanna play 93 and
we got I'm actually a win over French um
here Kara wanna deviated with e 5 I
think he usually doesn't play this so
maybe a bit of a surprise for the
Spanish play on it a 3 Queen B 6 so
queen bee success the old main line of
them advanced french Bishop e7 is a very
decent alternative which during the time
servers that have soo played the French
I always played a lot like this move
more but Queen B 6 is of course
perfectly alright grab played a three
this is some nowadays they only move
that is believed to post black any
problems ideas to go before at some
point and relieve the pressure on me to
UM it also covers the before square
which can be a rather useful um for
example if you look at Bishop e2 there
are sometimes some ideas for black to to
get this check in and this can be
irritating not an
exactly disposition but it can be
rotating so a three is a good move and
well I hope late night to h6 cm and the
recent defenders to russian
championships there was a fun game
between peter sweet land which you golf
where i would you have played now g27 i
covered this game a couple of weeks ago
if you're interested look in the channel
for swede line with you go for great
technical battle after 37 okay night h6
was played and before the exchanges and
night f5 so black gum has got everything
set on the default porn queen also so
why needs to cover this specially Bishop
to e3 there's also Bishop b2 possible
okay Black Plague Bishop d7 Bishop d3
yeah and now white might intend to take
so black felt inclined to take on only
three yeah here black has a couple of
alternatives um I think maybe the most
them mostly played in fear as if i'm not
mistaken that we should be seven let me
quickly check this i don't want to don't
want to tell you any nonsense yeah rook
c8 or Bishop e7 are the main rules allow
here vallejo whatever Paco is usually
car park called Paco Vice colleagues um
played g6 now come on g6 let's play were
just interesting I mean one idea can be
Bishop to g7 and then play f6 but it
also belongs to stay again a little bit
maybe even know Bishop h6 can be an idea
to a techie three so not bad but one
thing you really weaken those squares
need to be really cautious now about the
f6 and h6 square yeah here very
interesting the Quran applies 93 and
it's really interesting
if this was what is this is this a
planned sacrifice a planned and some
point some kind of preparation or it is
a blunder because what like is now able
to do is and well I hope late this he
just took on before and yeah bit of a
shock he takes BB should before and now
what is in a pit and it's a really
difficult to get out of this if white
would try to um yeah somehow cover all
this black has Luke c8 to increase the
pressure let's just say queen d to add
this is really bad rook c8 Brooke c1 and
queen a5 and yeah what are you doing
you'll lose this this back far for
nothing in particular I guess so it's
really interesting maybe this was all
planned but this could also be here just
the blunder which at the end turned out
to be perfectly all right because this
is the fun thing let look what happened
like took to come before and now simply
castles okay Black has no choice he
needs to grab the night now otherwise it
would simply move away like wrap the
night and look to see one attacking the
bishop yeah so what what about this
position Black has sacrificed two pawns
the whole Queen side but he got
something in return this bishop on c3 is
absolutely far away from here where it
actually would belong to cover both
squares on f6 and h6 so it can get to
really to really difficult and and
difficult to defend a dangerous attack
so let's see what happens rook c8 was
played now and here black had an
alternative it's very difficult to say
if this is what would have been better
like immediately could play Bishop to
before
on with the idea to get this Bishop back
for defense I'm the possible line just
to show what's possible 95 attacking f7
yeah here black for example could play
Bishop e7 which is an interesting idea
the idea being if night f7 you can
simply castle return one pawn and try to
yeah consolidate its it's not not at all
clear this position let's say something
like rook be one Queen c7 and Queen f3 I
really not sure what what this position
now is it's rather difficult only a
really really long analysis can can tell
what's what's going on Bishop e7 is one
idea like also you could consider just
castling in this position after which
White has more than one interesting
attack taking possibility of course you
can go with something like this but i
found this move interesting trying to
block this block off this this point on
f6 so that if black plays Bishop e7 you
can simply ignore it in will stir in
most cases and this has a pretty strong
threat let's say we should be seven just
for example then white can sacrifice he
on h7 and I think white is has got an
attack that is probably not possible to
do to defend against this is some losing
very simple very simple fashion with the
big fork and white having an extra piece
plus the attack so so Tara one cannot
take and of course you cannot take here
this is oops what's happened here we
should be seven oops officially seven
you cannot take on age seven at all
because queen age five will get you
mated very quickly check me so this is
the idea we hide the
us yeah and if black cannot take on f6
and not take on h7 then you know it's in
trouble so be sure before can also just
hear this Bishop before move is prob
maybe better hard to tell but white has
a dangerous attack in any case at least
he's got compensation for the two pawns
which is very funny I think that you can
sacrifice those two points but it's a
very weak side with those with those
some witnesses on g6 and h6 complaint
rook see item and here the first no move
95 versus obvious and castles so how
should white continue now I think here
on actually this Queen g4 move that Kara
wanna played you played this all very
quickly maybe this is really preparation
funny it would be really funny because
g6 is really a rare move okay um but he
had a good alternate just spent two
minutes here amazingly he had a good at
art if you and this is Ruby one would be
interesting just to to take the Queen
here and what should black play now if
black goes Queen d8 just for example
then there's routing of six idea again
and this is straightaway lost for black
really because this rook now prevents
black from ever retreating the bishop
and helping in defense and black simply
God's will get completely murdered here
I don't know what what like she should
do even white just goes here here and
then pressure through let's say for now
Queenie seven adjust just to put
something on the board and then again it
doesn't matter really also can go here
something just just something like this
in strife and now if you have whatever
there's multiple wins I guess maybe even
here with the threats now to take on g6
on e6 play g4 I mean what kind of
position is
is everything is on the king and this
piece simply doesn't help so rupee one
moving the Queen a sound yeah isn't
doing much good if you go here you set
yourself into a pin and it's the root
gave six and nine th seven to come yeah
I think black is probably simply lost
after rugby one I think there's no um
Noah play will defense anymore in the
game after you went Quincy find very
quickly and we spent two minutes on this
um black actually has a chance to save
himself and the first couple of moves
also played by a black here Queen h3
threatening a meteor so they try also
covering III so wyd exchange now and
Queen f3 so a tag on f7 yeah and here um
black only has exactly one playable move
but this is Sir is playable and fine for
him he can play Queen to c7 now just
covering this of course the issue is
this move right here black has a way to
to save himself can take with check so
what must react take here and yeah black
still is two pawns up by the way heard
sir still a pretty big material
advantage here white has trials of
course maybe you get six is an
interesting move after which black
shouldn't take probably this pond is is
getting very dangerous but it's not
necessary to take you can just play here
and let's say why dumb tries to increase
the pressure you go Queenie seven and
yeah that's it black is perfectly fine
young one funny point is some Queen a
night 2h7
and yeah of course black cannot take
because of evidence a what you can just
go here and it's a rather funny
perpetual of course and there are still
ideas yeah white can maybe play move
like here and that it continues this is
what black had to try it's simply the
only move playable this Queen to c7 or
move 20 we can go back I'm not saying
that maybe white would have one also
after Queen c7 but he simply must play
this there's no other move he played
rukka Queen to d8 after which white
simply takes and now black ken can
resign it's just over everything's
falling apart and what they what should
back to eat to 23 which wide simply
ignored of course taking here rook takes
it says not the best it's questionable
now if you get more than compensation
for the two points but you can simply
apply a king edge one I mean just ignore
this and threaten Bishop 36 and black
has no way to to keep all his pieces
together let Queen h4 Bishop to g6 and
yeah this piece is saying what should
you do went to g5 and now the final not
too difficult stroke is we should h7
check quite nice if black gum ignores
the bishop in place here is simply go to
d3 and Queen g6 his curtains and if
black takes it he resigned actually
after Bishop major 7 if black takes it
last night take g5 and after this ruger
7 is also coming so like we'll probably
get mated in a couple of moves didn't
analyze but it's winning in any case
yeah nice attacking game here about Kara
wanna but he really I wonder about a
couple of things I mean why did he play
this move
quickly after two minutes Ruby one is
really the far better move of course
it's easy to tell afterwards with
computer and so on but um you got down
like more than 40 extra minutes here on
the black player you can at least invest
the couple of minutes to to check out
the lines especially if you look at this
position why it's got everything on the
king i mean it's it's really a position
away trying to look for false mates at
least i would ever try to look for false
mates and i would really invest like 10
minutes or so to really figure out how
to kill black now and wonder why played
so quickly alright so very interesting a
game and also you have done yeah this
double blunder by a constant Aronian
very unusual yeah I hope you enjoyed
this brief coverage of the sau Paulo the
bow tournament I might return to this
tournament if I find something
interesting to present um but I don't
want to make this a kind of daily air
feature announced it's a bit much to
cover each round but if I find something
something interesting there be
additional videos of course yeah thanks
and talk to you soon